tonight we have a very special story
correspondent Benjamin Hall returns to
Ukraine 20 months after he was seriously
injured there while covering the war
with Russia also on the trip executive
chairman and CEO of Fox Corp Lan Murdoch
Benji Hall spoke exclusively with
Ukrainian President Vladimir zalinski
about the progress in the conflict and
his country's relationship with the
US
the last time I got onto this train I
was barely alive we badly injured but we
made it out the other side and today the
day that we're going back it's been a
long journey and we've come a long way
but inside Ukraine that Victory seems to
be getting further away with the war
being called a stalemate and an
acknowledgement that it will last for
years inside ke we pay tribute to all
those who have died amongst them our
colleagues Pier zakki and Sasha kushin
NOA and we spoke to president zalinski
both about the successes and the
hardships the eyes of the world have
moved elsewhere they're looking at
Israel how has that affected you yes you
are you are right uh it's it it doesn't
have good influence on
Ukraine it doesn't help us but we
understand that this is also a challenge
for for the world Middle East the
situation Middle East and we are trying
to help from our side how we can I know
that that is really really was big wish
of Russia to do it what they've been
what been done on the Middle East and
with the help of
Iranian their Iranian Partners a growing
number of Americans who think that the
money being spent in Ukraine is too much
so that should be spent in America what
would your message be to them to tell
them that this war does matter first of
all to Americans who been with us during
this war for their support but of course
if we are speaking about the Congress
about the unity around the help of
Ukraine of course this month is the
difficult interest many times we are
ready for co-production we're ready and
it can be win-win we need licenses and
we can produce air defense we will
defend Ukraine but also when you defend
with a great success the great results
we don't we your the the your pro
product that product of the United
States for example pet so the price will
be very high that is business and that
is important the second you will you
will when you produce it for for Ukraine
and with Ukraine you produce it also
with Americans so the part the big part
will be will be production in in your
States different states yes also in
Ukraine that is jobs for Americans and
for ukrainians it's very important I
hope that Congress will help us and I
hope that the help of United States will
be around Ukrainian people and I hope
that United States will be with us
against Russian terrorism so we are
fighting for common values it's very
important but we are losing our people
not losing Europeans Americans I'm not
wish you to have such you know of course
such war on your territory and I don't
wish you of course to lose your soldiers
you you you must be watching the US
election quite closely and of course
there already some splits on the
Republican side about support for
Ukraine president Trump has said that
you he could get a peace deal very
quickly let's speak with him and let him
give this
possibility to show what
steps what steps of his peace formula
would you like to sit down with him and
talk to him yes I'm ready I'm ready of
course if he has very concr peace plan
he can share it with me yes we can stop
this war if we will give Russia dbas and
Crimea to my mind that our country will
not be ready for such peace plan that is
not peace plan I just wonder if you see
this as the focal point of a battle but
between good and evil China Russia Iran
North Korea on one side the West on the
other and do you think that Ukraine is
right at the beginning of what could
become a wider conflict I I think that
yes Ukraine today in the center of of
these Global risks of the sword World
War and I really think that Russia will
push and uh until until the United
States and China together will tell them
very very seriously to go out of the
territory this year we didn't have such
success on the land but we had some
success in the Black Sea I think it was
also very smart idea in the Black Sea
and we had success and that's why if
Russia will not go out it
that politically politically in the
world we lose and the
world had these losses politically it
meant that Russia doesn't afraid of the
power of of the wol power do you feel
that without having advances on the
battlefield the counter offense of not
going as plan that sends a bad message
this is not the good message this is
true but uh I just want to say that we
are
we we staying strong it's difficult for
us yes we need more successful results
on the battlefield but we need it for us
first of all just want to share with you
that you when we speak about the results
on the battlefield when we speak about
the reforms first of all we need it we
ukrainians need it and then again I'm
sorry that I'm repeating such message
but but this is not movie we we you know
it's can't be magic
yes uh each day I think that we had
success in Crimea we had success in
Black Sea we really destroyed it mostly
the part of Russian fleit the Black Sea
Fleet we did it we moved them they don't
have such total influence on the black
SE Orion two of uh my team were killed
when I was injured Pierre our cameraman
and sash
and I know their families obviously
would think about that an awful lot I
wonder if you had message for them and I
wanted to say my condolences to all the
parents relatives of those very brave
guys men and women who lost their lives
because they really wanted to help
Ukraine to to be alive we
can't
um give you back I mean the your
alive sons and daughters but but we will
will'll never will'll never forget
it so Brett you know it was an
opportunity both to remember Pierre and
Sasha it was an opportunity to speak to
president zelinski in a way very few
people are able to and it was also an
opportunity to remind people that
journalism will never be stopped despite
the dangers and I think those were the
three things that we were really trying
to show out there Benjamin fantastic job
and it has to be remarkable to head back
into that country after all that you did
covering there and then how you came out
as you mentioned at the top at that
train you know president zilinski has
been a wartime president now for more
than 18 months now did you talk to him
about how he his family is coping with
all
this we did yes and in fact the one time
that he became somewhat emotional was
when he talked about his family he said
that he was fighting this battle for his
family as much as he was for Ukraine um
and he talked about how his children
cried in front of him sometimes take a
lesson to support your children
sometimes they you miss you very much
and sometime between us they they are
crying a little bit and you can't when
they cry you can't cry of course and
when you want to support your your
children or your or your wife and
sometimes your parents and you have
to to show that you're yes everything is
okay F sometimes find some jokes about
it jokes
help it's
really and I think that is the the
comedian in zinski coming out again so
he still has that in him and I know that
after the war he's hoping to get back to
something more like that yeah you know
Benjamin a lot of people obviously
assisted in the effort and and that hour
special uh about you getting out uh was
really powerful just wondering what you
thought as you hit the ground there you
obviously were traveling with u Fox
executive chairman CEO Lan Murdoch uh
representing all the folks who stood
behind you I mean we're very proud of of
how you handled all of it but your
thoughts and feelings when you got on
the ground well I think it was a
reminder to everyone that together we
can do almost anything and so we went
there together as a company and I was
brought out together as a company with
the doctors and the nurses and everyone
together so that was on my mind a lot
and I was lucky enough to be able to
meet some of the doctors and the nurses
who treated me back then but one of the
things that surprised me most is that I
was a little bit intimidated when I was
heading that way but I actually got off
that train in ke and I felt far more far
more strong than I had before because I
think it reminded me that you can go
through absolutely anything you can be
pushed down and bad things can happen
but together and we can remember this on
Thanksgiving together you can pick
yourself up you can go and do anything
you want again there should be no limits
to what you can do uh and I think
hopefully that's a message that we're
trying to
convey as a perfect message for
Thanksgiving and uh we give thanks uh
for you Benji great job thanks Brett hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else